how much involvement do you like
actually legitimately have on like that
game what what do they need from you
because we always hear about like mocap
and voice and all that sort of stuff
like you what did I just got in your
face and then go right go you're done
boy I would say I have the most
involvement ever I mean they needed me
they need this they needed those other
guys they need a John Cena Bray Wyatt
Cesaro
you know without us then there's no game
so I think I would I'm a very critical
point in this whole progression of video
gaming at this point um but it was it
was pretty neat because we did a lot of
scanning full-body scanning in and out
of the gear all different types of
movements flexing and yeah I mean you
can watch it right there just just how
fluid and it is the gameplay the
movement they did a great job of
studying you know that the athletes that
we are you know I move different than
Randy Orton and you can see that in the
game so I'm pretty impressed that it was
a good bit of work as far as you know
scanning and things like that but you
know if I'm not getting hit in the
forehead or thrown on the ground that's
pretty easy yeah well I mean if it needs
to be realistic then I mean obviously
they got a mocap you just you know
taking bombs getting out there doing
stuff right I mean if they want to get
that for then they need to get in the
ring yeah yeah getting injured and then
having to having to dial into
pay-per-views from the hospital
yeah do any mocap from a hospital bed
like we want realism here well they got
from realism there I'm sitting I'm
literally coming to like in and out of
anesthesia like you know just completely
out of my mind and like I'll see one
like one doctor and I go out and come
back see two nurses go out come back and
I see half our office and and already in
the room and I'm like why go out and
make say no hey can you do an interview
like oh there's light of champions kind
of cut that you did was that your bad
way I remember it in and out I mean in
like I have I have more vivid memories
be sure